(music)
Eric Schmidt:
I'm Eric Schmidt, Class of 1976.
I was an electrical engineering major because there was no
Eric Schmidt:
computer science, now there is, and I am now the CEO of Google.
It seems to me that people go to college, and then they join
Eric Schmidt:
their firms, and between the ages of 25 and 35 they learn a lot.
And then, all of a sudden, they want everything not to change.
Eric Schmidt:
And inevitably something new comes along: a new idea, a new fashion, a new country,
a new war, whatever, that upsets everything.
Eric Schmidt:
So the lesson to be learned after years of watching this is
that the norm must change.
Eric Schmidt:
What we want to do is we want to constantly reinvent
ourselves. Now it's easy to say that.
Eric Schmidt:
How do you do it? In our case, we encourage our
employees to spend 20 percent of their time working on whatever
Eric Schmidt:
they are interested in, not what their boss wants them
to work on. Out of that, most of our great new products have come.
Eric Schmidt:
Many different leadership styles work.
There's not one leadership style that is the way in which
Eric Schmidt:
corporations, institutions succeed.
You'll have passionate, charismatic and disorganized leaders.
Eric Schmidt:
You'll have boring and rational and precise leaders.
What really matters about a leader is their commitment to
Eric Schmidt:
getting to the right answer and to doing it in the right way.
And however they get there, if they get to the right
Eric Schmidt:
answer, people respect them.
Along the way, you'll have conflict and you
Eric Schmidt:
can resolve it in many different ways. If you don't seek out the
conflict, you won't excel.
Eric Schmidt:
Because without the conflict, at least the ideas in conflict,
you won't hear the best ideas.
Eric Schmidt:
When I thought about where to go to college,
everyone assumed I would go to a technical school,
Eric Schmidt:
someplace where people with my interests would go.
But I was attracted to Princeton precisely because
Eric Schmidt:
engineering was not its primary focus.
And I believe that the value of a liberal arts education just in
Eric Schmidt:
general, just learning about the world
and learning about other people, would serve me in some inchoate
Eric Schmidt:
way, some way in which I really didn't know.
And that's proven true --
Eric Schmidt:
that the skills and in particular the social
experiences and exposure to the non-technical part of the
Eric Schmidt:
world as a young person, made a huge difference for me.
In my case, I met a brilliant professor who got me interested
Eric Schmidt:
in computing and got me interested in the foundations of
the kinds of things I did after I left Princeton.
Eric Schmidt:
So it was the combination of critical thinking and the fact
that you had such good access to professors who you could really
Eric Schmidt:
talk to, that as a very, very young
person had a huge impact on me.
Eric Schmidt:
My name is Eric Schmidt, and I'm a Princeton Engineer.
(music)